je suis candidat parce que je pense
avoir un profil idoine pour cette
fonction la mesure où je suis encarté
dans un parti politique et j'ai la
réputation ne reconnaît comme étant un
homme calme pondéré qui fait consensus
c'est d'ailleurs vous croire de mon
groupe on a choisi et puis aussi je veux
aller au sénat parce que dans la
situation exceptionnelle dans laquelle
nous sommes la martinique se trouve je
parle même pas du du chômage et de tout
cela mais deux des difficultés et des
menaces qui pèsent sur nous avec un
nouveau gouvernement
réduction drastique des moyens des
communes
je veux y aller pour porter des idées
nouvelles pour augmenter les ressources
de nos communes et de nos collectivités
territoriales étant un homme qui
recherche le consensus
je veux travailler avec tous les autres
parlementaires faire un front commun
pour que nous puissions faire pour le
gouvernement car la situation
exceptionnelle laquelle nous sommes il
faut des mesures exceptionnelles mesure
qui n'affecte pas davantage le porte
monnaie des contribuables